hello in a 2022 War returned to Europe
Russia invaded Ukraine on the 24th of
February and that action has had a
profound and Lasting effect on the world
the Russian attack forced millions of
people from their homes and caused a
global food and energy crisis and will
continue to impact Millions around the
world for years to come now over the
past 10 months Sky's defense and
security analyst Professor Michael
Clarke has been giving us his insight as
to how the war has played out I'm Kamali
Melbourne and in the next 30 minutes
Mike will be giving us his expert
opinion on the key elements of the war
in Ukraine and on what could come next
but before we begin let's take a look at
the key moments of the war so far
the wreckage of Russian Vehicles is
littering this street
there we go it started before Dawn
[Music]
can you hear that Mark
[Music]
it's the only way out of European and
this would test even the fit and healthy
but those still fleeing are the most
vulnerable
they are going west to safety he will
now Head East to fight there is going to
be one Almighty Crush as people try to
get on
rods going up behind you now
whatever fell from the sky made a crater
this big and it's Crawford from Sky News
clawed the sky and stop bombing don't
don't speak about the bureaucratic steps
you can see what's left of the missile
here the words on the side of that
zadeti it means four children this is
what it's like in kharkiv every day at
first we were scared really scared but
now we are ready to fight fights like
hell precious monuments are now shrouded
in sandbags
so through here the
making the molotov cocktails Vladimir
Putin thought that Russian forces would
capture Kiev within days
they failed instead his forces are bolt
down in a war
that they're unwilling to leave and so
far incapable of winning they're very
grateful to see something that they
didn't think they would see
[Music]
if ever at all
well the War Began on the 24th of
February its lead up was months if not
years in the making before we begin
Michael let's just understand Ukraine in
Europe and where it finds itself it yes
it's the biggest land area in Europe
apart from Russia itself so it's the
biggest country 44 million people so
again it's quite large and it's
potentially very rich not so rich these
days but it is potentially very rich and
it has the the great Nipper river
running through it and that divides the
country into sort of an Eastern third
which is more industrial a more Russian
influenced in its history and a western
two-thirds which is much more
Agricultural and more influenced by
Poland and Lithuania in history so it's
an interesting country and a major
country in Europe uh as and when it
catches up with West European economies
yeah and tell us about the man
Prosecuting this well the man who
decided to evade President Vladimir
Putin when the Soviet Union collapsed in
1991 he was in Dresden as the KGB Chief
in a small town he was appalled by what
he saw he thought it was a catastrophe
that the Soviet Union had broken up and
it was Ukraine that effectively broke up
the Soviet Union it was their demands
for Independence that created the
momentum that broke up the rest he never
forgave them for that never accepted
that Ukraine could be an independent
country tree had his own view of Russian
history there was a crisis in 2014 when
Ukraine began to lean much too far he
thought to the European Union and out of
that crisis they occupied Crimea by
force they occupied parts of the donbass
about a third of it with these
separatist territories and that gave him
the beginnings of a war in 2022 for a
range of other reasons he thought the
moment was right and this common land
border two thousand kilometers then
becomes very important because the
Russians sent for the third time a
series of of exercises into Belarus and
into Western Russia and these exercises
they said I would just exercise and the
West was saying well these don't look
just like exercise it looks as if you
plan to do something no no just an
exercise the troops themselves thought
they were only on exercise so they
didn't really prepare properly they sold
a lot of their equipment they didn't get
themselves ready only three people
around Putin 72 hours before The
Invasion knew what he intended even
grazimov the chief of the general staff
he didn't know until three days before
and then on the 24th of February
suddenly these exercises became an
invasion they crossed the 2 000
kilometer border and for Kiev there's no
way of Defending yourself against that
no and with all that build up how did
Kiev defend itself how do they prepare
themselves in those well militarily they
tried to defend themselves by Going Back
to Basics after 2014 that crisis and
they began to build a western-style army
based on Western principles but the
political class they just pretended it
wasn't happening they really didn't want
to hear this so they listened to those
people who said no no this is just an
exercise they wanted to believe the
Russians and effectively they just ran
out of rope and it was 24 hours before
The Invasion before Kiev really
understood what was about to happen they
hope it was so awful they just couldn't
believe it would really take place
foreign
so as the war broke out Michael let's
examine where we are six days into the
fighting what's the situation yeah after
six days all these red areas represented
Parts where the Russians were making
progress now clearly making progress in
the South because they were coming from
Crimea where their lines of
communication were much shorter and
their forces were better so they were
doing as they would have expected to do
here and around this other areas they
were making progress and we all expected
these to turn into arrows of quite big
advances and when people were discussing
what are the Russians are going to do we
thought what they will probably do is
try to take all of the land east of the
NEPA river that would be logical they
they would then say this is ours and
then then start a discussion about what
would happen to the rest of Ukraine and
try and make it into a effectively an
unviable state that seemed to be logical
we thought that this was getting getting
off to a slightly slow start but we
fully expected this whole area east of
the nepra to turn red within a matter of
weeks right let's focus in now on the
capitals of course to take the country
they would have wanted to take Kiev and
there was a key battle held just as side
the Ukrainian capital in and around
Hospital airport that was really
critical the Russians put their
paratroopers into Hospital airports in
the early hours the job was getting to
hostel Mill go to Kiev get hold of the
government kill zielinski and anybody
else around him and then get more troops
into hospital to take control of the
capital once you're in control of the
capital 72 hours is what they expected
will then suppress any problems we have
in Sumi and Cherno have within a few
weeks the Russians felt that by about
the eighth or 10th of March it would all
be over and that was the idea their
failure to take hostile metal or to hold
it they took it and then the Ukraine's
Got it back within hours that failure
cost them the the rapid strategy that
might otherwise have worked and how many
airborne troops they managed to land at
a hospital well it was a couple of
battalions worth originally and then
they were going to flood troops into the
place with with air power and
helicopters and so on once you've got an
Airfield you can do all sorts of things
with it you can get thousands and
thousands of troops and equipment in but
the fact that they didn't hold it meant
that they were having to operate from
long distances and critically Kiev just
didn't get give in and the fact was a
lot of saboteurs in Kiev a lot of
Spetsnaz people who were designed
actually to create trouble there's an
awful lot of rough Justice a lot of
firing at night in the streets we don't
still don't know the story of all of
that I think it will emerge that a lot
of people were killed out of hand as the
ukrainians actually suppressed these
sabotage squads that were in place
already and these early days Michael
people will remember that this was the
moment where we saw that traffic jam on
the way down into Kiev coming out for
the prepared marshes tell us about that
and how significant that was yes quite
quickly this big column started to came
across the prep marshes and it was
coming southwards and we all thought
okay this is the the encirclement of
care this will come South in circle Kiev
uh forced from Sumi who were making
quite good progress they only encircle
from the from the East and Kiev will be
completely encircled and then we'll see
what happens well the Russians dare to
bombard it this great city founded in
482 with a really bombarded City that
ancient much older than Moscow or they
just squeeze it we didn't know the fact
is they didn't get closed captioning not
available
foreign
[Music]
of course but Michael let's go back to
the First full calendar month of the war
the 31st of March describe for us the
situation at that point yeah Kamali by
then it had turned into a sort of War of
the Cities the the original strategy
take care within 72 hours and finish it
that had failed and so now the Russians
seem to be occupying or the area around
cities they weren't able to get into
them couldn't get into car give couldn't
get it they did get into curse on but
other cities they weren't able to get
into and so they stood outside of them
Kirsten was the only city that they took
mainly because it was sort of given to
them by collaborators in effect and that
was the only important city that they
had and in a sense this was almost like
four separate campaigns four different
areas all run by local commanders nobody
was in overall control we were watching
this and thinking we can't really see
the strategy behind this this was just
activity almost for its own sake didn't
seem to be going anywhere that's on the
Russian side no overall strategy but
let's move to the summer and the
Ukrainian counter offensive because
there was some definite strategy behind
this and some pre-planning yes um I mean
by the summer the Russians had taken
Ferry Donetsk after a hundred days of of
uh of attack and then they quite quickly
Chuck Lisha chance this is actually the
only good bit of maneuver Warfare they
conducted they got behind Ukrainian
Defenders Alicia chance they had a good
defensive position in the ukrainians
they had to give it up or they were
going to get surrounded so they moved
back and we all thought okay the next
battle is the final battle for the
donbass which is slavy ants and
chromatos slaviansk very important
symbolically that's where the 2014
Revolt started by the luhan's People's
Republic and kramatosk is the center for
Road and rail particularly Railways if
the Russians took that then they get the
rest of the donbass and the ukrainians
had made a fortress of both of those
places so we thought right that's the
next battle but actually the Russians
didn't get any further than Alicia
chance this was the high water mark of
their advance in the donbass yeah the
ukrainians were able to punch through in
that uh part of the East uh while at the
same time they were also focusing in on
trying to retake Kirsten they were they
talked about retaking person quite a lot
uh and we all thought okay well it's a
neat trick if you can do it see how long
it takes you but while they were talking
about that they persuaded the Russians
mainly Putin to transfer troops from the
donbass down to Gerson and then the
ukrainians hit them in the donbass and
they retook isium isium have been a very
important center for the ukrainians uh
the Russians have taken it we're basing
their forces from Islam uh the
ukrainians took it back and they pushed
them right back until they were fighting
then on the edge effectively of severed
Donetsk by the end of the year and that
offensive has been extraordinarily
effective and Michael by this point as
we can see on the map here Mario poll on
the sea of azov is in Russian hands and
that was a long and grinding battle for
that yes it became the sort of symbol of
the war the Dave and Goliath War I was
always saying at the beginning I thought
maripole would fall within hours it
should have done because it was right on
the on the edge of the battle area but
it didn't and I don't know how they kept
on fighting at Mario Paul but they did
mainly the Marines and the azov regiment
and a couple of other
um units and the Russians became
obsessed with the as of style steel
works the ukrainians Disappeared into
the steel Works which had lots of
underground bunkers built by the Soviets
in case of a nuclear attack there's no
way they could be wrinkled out of there
and instead of just screening mariopol
and then moving on which is where the
the Russians needed to send their forces
North they became almost obsessed with
it and so it became a symbol of the war
and the although Mario Paul was
eventually taken by the Russians the
survivors of Mario Paul are now the sort
of Ukrainian Heroes of this war and they
will be for a couple of generations all
right let's move on now from the summer
and to Autumn going into winter and this
is the moment where Ukraine were able to
retake that city of Kirsten on the 12th
of November yes
um the ukrainians had launched these
large attacks around snow Rifka but
about 60 kilometers wide very ambitious
and we thought will they really be able
to get through there but what they were
reflecting was the fact that um the
Russians had failed to take McLeod
earlier in the war and by failing to
take McLeod and therefore they couldn't
get on to Odessa further west that meant
that all these troops who were west of
the nipro were not doing any good what
were they there for other than to occupy
more or less empty ground and the
Russian generals wanted to withdraw them
Putin said No at least twice that we're
aware of eventually the ukrainians put
their put them under enough pressure
particularly at novakovka and then in
Kirsten itself and the Russians withdrew
and the fact is they Kirsten the Ukraine
didn't have to fight for Kirsten and the
Russians therefore pretend that it
wasn't really a defeat but it was a
tremendous defeat because it was the
only city of any importance that they
had they withdrew and now the ukrainians
have got all of the area west of the
NEPA River and by this point in the war
Michael the Russians have a new general
in charge on the ground a general
surveykin yeah so
he is he actually has imposed some
coherence on Russian strategy he said we
would draw troops from areas where
they're not doing any good we only fight
the battles we want to fight and we will
pressurize the public in Ukraine he said
he said I'm not going to fight a
guerrilla war against NATO Fanatics he
said we have technical means that was
his phrase technical means of making
Ukraine Surrender by which they mean
making that life as miserable as
possible for the civilian population so
the gloves are off it's clear this is a
war to subjugate Ukraine the country 44
million people to Russia's will sorry
vegan is responsible for the honesty of
that policy and Michael what have we
seen in terms of the way that he's
trying to fight the way because he told
us the way he fought War when he was
bombing cities in Syria he's a man who
just does what he thinks it takes I mean
he's famous for bombing Hospital
facilities first as a way of creating
more civilian misery he's he just thinks
in terms of Russian soldiers okay
Michael for now thank you very much for
that now coming up after the break
Michael and I will be discussing the
ever-present threat of nuclear weapons
being used and we'll also look ahead to
what may come next in the war in 2023
[Music]
hello and welcome back to this Sky News
special on the war in Ukraine with
Professor Michael Clarke
[Music]
now one of President Putin's stated
grievances Before the War Began was
Western military encroachment on Russia
now as the war's gone on there's been
greater and increasing NATO involvement
we've got the map of Europe up here
Michael and we can see the NATO
countries marked tannenblood you can see
they come right up to the Russian border
yes I mean the NATO countries are marked
in blue and in dark blue are Finland and
Sweden who
um are not quite members yet but almost
certainly will become members pretty
soon and what this represents is Putin's
worst nightmare because NATO has
enlarged itself since 1949 nine times
never tried to enlarge itself it's
always responding to demands everybody
wants to join NATO and six of those nine
enlargements has been why Putin has been
in the Kremlin so what he's seen is the
old the old Europe that he was aware of
when he was a KGB Chief in Dresden had a
an iron curtain that ran across there
that was the border that he had to worry
about now the border is around here and
that's a thousand miles nearer to Moscow
that really worries him because he only
sees Security in territorial terms and
he also sees the sheer strength of
Europe I mean even leaving aside the
United States and Canada Europe has a
population three and a half times bigger
than Russians it has a GDP 12 times
bigger than Russia's and yet because
Russia is ruled by an angry victimized
autocrat who is very aggressive we all
have to be very careful how we handle
them and talk to us more broadly about
the Global Response because there has
been Global condemnation of the attack
but not from everyone no exactly I mean
the United Nations met very soon after
the invasion and 141 States condemned
Russia roundly in the in the general
assembly but Fortune States didn't and
those states included 35-36 who
abstained and five who voted in favor of
the uh of the Russian invasion and those
those who didn't vote to condemn
represent more than half of the world's
population so essentially half the
world's population are standing back to
see what happens and half the world's
population are outraged by what has
happened and talks about the support
that NATO and the West are provided to
Ukraine through financing and of course
through military means yes I mean the
um West has given Ukraine a lot of
technical help a lot of Finance about
between five and nine billion dollars a
month just to keep going and a lot of
weapons ultimately the the West is
determined that Ukraine must not lose
this war the West isn't isn't clear what
will happen next where this is leading
us but where it mustn't lead us in the
view of Western capitals is to the
defeat of Ukraine to this naked
aggression easy to say that's harder to
do when Putin tries to put pressure
particularly on Europe to go to go hard
on Ukraine through enter into some sort
of negotiation yeah and part of that
pressure comes from the threat of
nuclear weapons 10 months of a war with
a nuclear-armed power that threat will
always be there but it's not just
nuclear weapons that's the danger in
this particular conflict no I mean Putin
has always talked about nuclear weapons
for the very beginning of the war he
talked about nuclear dangers he's the
only one who did nobody else talked
about nuclear dangers the Americans
wound down their normal nuclear their
drills so as not to be provocative the
Russians increased all their nuclear
drills so that they were basically
rattling their nuclear weapons with
everybody else nobody takes him that
seriously to be honest and the and the
the Chinese and the Indians are very
worried about his nuclear rhetoric
however the nuclear threat that really
does arise is the possibility of a
nuclear accident at Chernobyl or
zaparizio or any of the other three or
four nuclear plants that the ukrainians
run because although the reactors are
all powered down for safety reasons they
depend upon electricity to remain safe
and if they're cut off by the bombing
from uh constant electricity then the
danger of an accident is always ever
present and that's the real nuclear
danger that there might be another
Chernobyl
[Music]
so Michael talk to us about the ways
this war could come to an end
well there are three possible scenarios
one is that Russia wins which is to say
that the offensive in the spring is
successful a win back a fair bit of
territory and the Western powers are
sufficiently upset by the whole
disruption that the wars caused to lean
on Kiev to go into some sort of
negotiation so Putin walks away with
some gains from The Invasion the second
scenario is the Ukraine wins which is
the opposite of all of that that the
ukrainians managed to push the Russians
out of most of all the territories
they've taken since February and maybe
some more whether or not that includes
Crimea and Putin pays a price for that
failure that then Ukraine wins the third
scenario which I have to say is probably
the most likely is that this is a
generational struggle this will go on
for a couple of generations which means
20 or 30 more years remember the Balkans
is in in explosive State that's 30 year
old conflict still ongoing in effect so
30 years is not long for a conflict to
take place but the fighting will be on
off on off over a long period I suspect
that that's what we're going into
well on that then at this point in the
war at this Vantage Point can we see
what the lasting impact of this conflict
will be well the lasting impact is that
it proves yet again that a war anywhere
is a problem everywhere in the world
because this Ukraine war has created a
food crisis it's contributed to currency
crises it's contributed to trade crises
it has
um Regional implications in the Baltic
Sea uh in the Mediterranean in other
parts of Europe this war can't be
contained even though the fighting is
all in relatively small parts of Ukraine
the war itself is a big event and one of
the things that has impressed the
Chinese is how they've not been able to
stand back from this they are affected
by the war their economy is affected by
it and their prospects are affected by
it and they have seen the West be much
more cohesive than they expected and if
the Chinese are thinking of something
similar in Taiwan they are certainly
thinking twice as to whether they could
take Taiwan militarily if the West can
continue to be as cohesive as it has
been during this uh period of the war
well the final thought there is that on
the west can it continue to be as
cohesive as it is well this winter is a
tough time this is when it all gets more
difficult because we've got to get
through this winter get through all of
the shortages and the high prices for
energy and come out through the other
side but next year if the West can
remain cohesive if it can remain United
in its opposition and its determination
to make sure that the ukrainians Prevail
in this conflict then things will get a
lot better because the balance of
advantages turns against the Russians
from the spring next year if the
ukrainians can hold the big offensive
which we know the Russians are preparing
for the spring
Professor Michael Clarke always
appreciate your analysis thank you very
much for being with us now for more on
this you can of course go to our website
talk to the Sky News app and for the
very latest coverage on the war in
Ukraine do stay with us here on Sky News
[Music]